y'all trying to watch some of them
summer games tonight he'll cheer the
dream team playing how we're gonna be a
dream team without LeBron more like a
lean team ain't no way they winning a
gold without the King her Bron Bron
didn't want to go to Rio de Janiero
because of Zika Zika you mean that big
booty mami who'll be popping it on our
snaps no it's like to pursue any bone
it's supposed to make your head shrink
man CK ain't real Brazil made that
up so you can win some mental ain't
nobody trying to watch basketball anyway
I stay on that gymnastics yeah those
dudes is super huh but hey trying to see
all their mammal toes I'm talking about
women's gymnastics then leotards they
wear be showcasing damn push knuckle
yeah but gymnast body's too compact on
the Brazilian volleyball booty can
handle this nein
what about ice skating down that's the
Winter Games dumbass dude what do you
got a singer King imma segregate your
asses to the parking lot if y'all don't
get your hands in the game
can't you see we conversating team have
some manners bunch of ungrateful ass